Benjamin Netanyahu said anti-zionism is
anti-Semitism of course he said that
do you disagree absolutely I disagree
what's the gap between
um anti-zionism and anti-Semitism those
who are against the policies of
uh Israel versus those who are against
the Jewish people
I watched the well the first like 20
minutes and then I couldn't do it
anymore you know but I watched and then
what was interesting about Netanyahu is
that he said you know being
being anti-zionist is like saying I'm
okay with the Jews I just don't believe
the Jews have a right to form their own
State that's like
saying I'm okay with Americans I'm just
not okay with Americans having their own
State and there is so much wrong with
that statement in the sense that
Jewish people are a religious group in
Americans and America being an American
is a nationality that consists of
A diversity
um of religions and
and so on and so forth first of all on
the second the second thing that's wrong
with that statement is the whole idea
that states somehow have a right to
exist or or whatever it's it's such a
destruction you have you have people
getting shot in the street you have like
millions and millions of people besieged
you have people losing their homes you
have people who are held in Israeli
prisons without trial
um or charts indefinitely but the
conversations that are being held in the
on the hill the conversations that are
being held on CNN
or does Israel has a right to exist or
like why would you negate Israel's
having a right to exist that's one now
of course I'm sorry and I just I just
find it's it's ridiculous again like
that opposing a secular political
movement that was explicitly colonialist
expansionist exclusive and racist
through the words of its own authors is
somehow and also again opposing such a
political movement that is
quite young and quite recent is somehow
equivalent equivalent to opposing uh a
religion that is thousands and thousands
of years old but it is convenient
again for Israeli politicians
to frame us who oppose Zionism
a form of racism and bigotry as
anti-semites but I can guarantee you
Benjamin Netanyahu has no problem with
anti-Semitism this is the same man who
has no problem getting on stage and
shaking hands with Pastor John Hagee
doing uh web webinars with Pastor John
Hagee for those who don't know Pastor
John Hagee is the founder of Christians
United for Israel who has said on
multiple occasions that Hitler was a
hunter who who was sent to hunt the Jews
who said on multiple occasions that
Jewish people are going to perish in
hell you can all of this is like
verifiable by Google
and this is one of the Israeli regime's
closest allies right
um
so the Israeli regime does not have a
problem with anti-semites when it serves
its interests it has a problem
I mean like if you look at Evangelical
Evangelical evangelicals or like
Christian Zionism at Lords
semitism lies at the heart
of Christian Zionism it's the idea that
we want to derive all of the Jews
outside of the United States so that
Armageddon could happen or whatever the
[__] this accusation has been a muzzle
it has been used as a muzzle
to silence political opposition
um and to stifle political advocacy for
the liberation of Palestine and a lot of
the time people get caught up in
denouncing it and in
justifying themselves and disclaimers
and so on and so forth that you lose the
point that you're distracted from the
focal point that is there is an ongoing
colonialism happening where people every
single day are killed I cannot keep
count this morning
a kid was shot
in Palestine
we cannot it's embarrassing even for me
that I don't even know the numbers here
but this muzzle has been effective and I
think the only
writes with uh
option is to oppose these labels these
smear campaigns that Target us I myself
have been labeled an anti-semite
by the ADL and I mean like if you want
to talk about
the surface level people people say like
wow the ADL until defamation League you
know uh condemned you but people do not
look at the history of the
Anti-Defamation League do not look at
the present of the anti-defamition
league the fact that they are
um
the largest non-governmental police
training uh Department in the country
where they train police and
uh racial profiling and militarism the
fact that they have historically and
continued to have engaged in
surveillance on
on black black liberation movements on
anti-apartheid South African activists
most recently in Charlottesville when
white supremacists were marching
um and chanting anti-semitic [__] the
ADL advised local police departments to
spy on the black organizers opposing the
white supremacists this is again all
verifiable on the internet go to drop
the adl.org so the ADL does not
uh alleviate the uh
the hate in the world
as it probably is designed to do no it's
it's the guys I don't think the
apartheid Defense League is really our
most Progressive but that's what it
stands for yeah in case you don't know
now you know